bonjour sophy tissier merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france alors
dans un premier temps que pensez vous de
cette volonté de modifier l'article 24
du projet de loi sécurité globale il
faut effectivement de toute façon
s'opposer à cette loi dans son ensemble
nous on organise pour cette raison une
manifestation demain dabou je ne vous
entends pas très bien donc j'ai pas tout
à fait suivi qui s'est dit juste avant
non s'opposent à cette loi clairement il
faut que la liberté de filmer soit au
coeur de faim de des décisions
politiques on ne peut pas laisser passer
cette loi en l'état
demain on s'oppose à cette loi mais
également on dénonce l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui impose des privations de
liberté on considère qu'aujourd'hui il
ya plus important que cette loi il ya
des millions de français qui se
retrouvent privés de ne pouvoir exercer
leur profession priver d'aller et venir
tout simplement et c'est la liberté
fondamentale qui est aujourd'hui
attaquée par l'état d'urgence sanitaire
nous c'est la première raison pour
laquelle on manifeste demain à votre
avis quelle est la volonté du
gouvernement à travers cette loi quel
est le projet concret du gouvernement
la loi sécurité global testing c'est une
loi fourre tout mais c'est une loi qui
va aussi augmenter les prérogatives
fallait les moyens de la police qui va
permettre de davantage pister les tous
les manifestants les opposants
politiques
on voit que ça peut être une dérive
dictatoriale clair et ça ouvre la voie à
davantage de surveillance massive de
tous les individus donc empêcher la
liberté vous savez moi ya deux semaines
j'ai passé une journée en garde à vue je
considère que c'était une arrestation
abusive
on m'accusait d'avoir organisé une
manifestation illégale alors qu'elle
avait été déclaré en bonne et due forme
et j'ai passé huit heures en garde à vue
donc on voit que la police peut déborder
le préfet peut déborder de ceux de son
autorité et sa absolument pas normal là
aujourd'hui voyez je me trouve devant le
conseil d'état on va intenter une
requête
aujourd'hui pour faire a ajouté le motif
de participation à une manifestation sur
l'attestation de circulation officielle
pour que tous les citoyens français
savent sache qu'on a le droit de
manifester
voilà parce qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
gens n'osent pas venir en manif de peur
d'être d'être d'avoir des amendes et des
de se revoir de recevoir un pv
donc il faut absolument que chacun ait
conscience que notre liberté de
manifester elle est sacrée que c'est au
fondement même de notre constitution
donc on doit la défendre c'est pour ça
que à l'instant je vais être reçu avec
notre avocat david wolf dans une requête
au conseil d'état pour demander a ajouté
ce motif de participation une manif
déclaré et demain nous organisons la
manif autres cadero avec force jaune
nous avons vu qu'il ya eu énormément
d'appels des syndicats la ligue des
droits de l'homme des partis politiques
à venir également au trocadéro ils ne
nous ont pas avertis mais bon on
accueille tout le monde il faut que tout
le monde se fasse unités dans ce combat
pour la liberté pour la démocratie et
fasse barrage à la dictature en marche
qui en place avec cet état d'urgence
sanitaire qui nous impose
ddd privation de liberté et qui permet à
l'état aussi de faire passer des lois
complètement liberticides et aujourd'hui
on doit vraiment faire unité nous en
tant que peuple pour défendre nos droits
nos libertés c'est hyper important
aujourd'hui c'est notre priorité
alors ce jeu s'enfuit dit fier
vous qui êtes habitués un des
manifestations qu'est-ce que ça va
changer concrètement cette loi si elle
est appliquée à votre façon de
manifester clairement on doit protéger
dans manifestants à tout prix évidemment
que on a subi tous des répressions même
dans les manifs que nous avions déclaré
il ya une manif au trocadéro le 23
février 2019 ou des personnes se sont
pris des coups de pied des coups de
matraque dans le par des policiers de
façon complètement gratuite et hyper
violente et c'était pas du tout
justifiée dans le maintien de l'ordre
nous l'avons dénoncée à l'époque
c'étaient des manifs que nous déclarions
où il y avait énormément de monde et il
est vrai qu'il ya dans le maintien de
l'ordre aujourd'hui des grosses réformes
à faire
et sûrement pas plus d'autoritarisme
plus de surveillance plus de contrôles à
on doit former les policiers à pouvoir
encadrer les manifestations et pas à
augmenter une violence gratuite sous
prétexte de maintien de l'ordre
voilà et selon vous pourquoi il est
important qu'on puisse a continué à
filmer à photographier les policiers
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions et
surtout en cas de manifestation
c'est la base c'est la base il faut
pouvoir tout est public une
manifestation c'est public le travail
des fonctionnaires et publique un
fonctionnaire des forces de l'ordre et
fait partie du domaine public j'ai envie
de dire moi en 2015 savez je participe à
une manifestation des policiers m'ont
arrêté et j'ai eu le genou abîmé et en
représailles un policier m'a accusé de
l'avoir frappé au visage déjà eu une
plainte contre moi d'un commandante
paulissen grâce à la vidéo d'un ami on a
pu y m'innocenter est prouvé que je
n'avais strictement rien fait donc ça va
dans tous les sens pour innocenter des
manifestants qui sont accusés à tord et
pour prouver quand la police déborde et
ne respecte pas ça devait anthologie
donc c'est ultra important c'est
vraiment cette loi ne doit absolument
pas passer en l'état parce qu'elle va
permettre même si enfin vous rendez
compte floutées des images en direct
c'est impossible et on doit pouvoir
rendre compte en direct de ce qui se
passe c'est le droit à l'information qui
fait partie des droits fondamentaux
aussi qui garantissent une démocratie
saine merci beaucoup sophie tissier
d'avoir été avec nous
cet après midi sur rt france je rappelle
que vous êtes coordinatrice de
l'association gilet jaune merci force
jaune pardon merci beaucoup